I've lost more money than most people
have ever made
[Music]
all right I've got a couple interesting
topics today the biggest one
and this is more
what we're gonna do right now is I want
I want to do something that I only do
privately I'll do it publicly I like it
yeah that could go different
that could go different ways but you
could critique me but basically like
with some of my friends and some people
in Hampton I do this thing called a
portfolio review where I explain my
financial portfolio and you are allowed
to critique it and challenge me in order
to like hopefully make me better okay uh
you know you know what I'm saying I know
exactly what you're saying you don't
have to keep asking I know what you were
saying
you know what I'm saying
you asked this question a lot to Our
Guest I think it first started with Ryan
holiday and I thought it was like just
the most blunt wonderful question you go
so what do you do with your money
and I thought that was wonderful and so
that's kind of how I like came up with
the idea to do this and so I figured
today we can do that does that sound
interesting to you yeah let's do it all
right the portfolio review and I guess I
think we're going to do this like the
other way I like to ask the question is
if there was a pie chart you know
roughly what percent are you putting
over here what percent are you putting
over there and why and I'm not like one
of those guys so our friend Nick Huber
sent an email out the other day and he
put like exact numbers of everything of
his net worth and there's a bunch of
people who do that I'm not that
transparent so I don't I don't
particularly like that but I'll be very
transparent about something yeah we're
not going financially streaking here but
um you know yeah if we can go to the
beach
I'll take my shirt off
yeah yeah yeah we're gonna go we're
gonna pop the top but we're not we're
keeping the bottoms on right
um
okay so um
first let me say my strategy for this
whole thing the first thing is that a
lot of this is contingent on my previous
strategy which I started when I was like
21 years old was to start and sell a
business by the age of 30. I thought if
I did that that would give me some
Financial Security which was basically
rooted in like being insecure about
money for a very long time and wanting
to have like some type of security
so that's like a lot of people listening
in the YouTube comments I know they're
gonna say but how did you get like blank
well we talked about that a ton but
anyway it was about starting and selling
a company another thing
unlike you Sean and I think unlike most
of our listeners I would say I am
incredibly conservative and so that is
not the right Fit For A lot of people
right the reason I'm conservative is I'm
gonna break it down into four different
accounts of which my big major account I
consider that account my livable money
so I don't actually draw off any of it
but my game plan was to sell a business
and have that big windfall if I wanted
to it could just go into uh the stock
market and the gains could pay for the
rest of my life without ever having to
touch the principal
so that's kind of like uh the strategy
on that and then also as of now I
currently live off of my income so we
make income from this podcast from our
other companies my wife works so I live
off that money so I don't actually touch
anything just explains I think without
numbers it's hard let's pretend for a
second
that when you sold the hustle you made
10 million dollars after taxes let's
just pretend that's true yeah what
you're saying is you put 10 million
dollars in Vanguard index and that's
you're basically like if I need it
that's there I'm financially independent
but you don't want to touch it and so
you live you pay your bills off of
things like this podcast or you know
people buying your digital products or
random stuff like that that's like kind
of money and money out that's your
that's how you fund your lifestyle and
you can do whatever you want and then
you have this Nest Egg that's there
that's basically what you're saying was
your kind of strategy from 20s was
basically live cheap build a company
sell it so you have that Nest Egg now
you're like I got The Nest Egg and I
have this income Source that's that's
pretty strong that pays for all of my
lifestyle stuff what now specifically
the way that I had planned on it was
let's say you had 10 million dollars you
can draw out three percent of that per
year and basically your nut your
portfolio that 10 million dollars would
hypothetically and mostly realistically
based off 100 Years of data continue to
grow each year some years it actually
wouldn't some years avoid but it would
average to uh Each decade it would grow
uh yes and that number is three percent
that I hypothetically would pull out of
course I don't but I could and then
finally
my strategy is to reduce stress and to
make income from my private companies
and so I am not an active investor of
which we are going to see and also this
is not advice I don't know anything so
don't actually do anything I'm saying
I'm just telling you what I do all right
also if this were advice this is like
the financial equivalent of like try
missionary right it's like you know
you're not even gonna like this
portfolio review is not going to be like
it's some like crazy backdoor sweep
that's you know it puts over here some
calls over there like I'm pretty sure
what you're gonna say is that by the
index uh buy some bonds and then I try
to build more wealth through my private
businesses did I already did I spoil
your portfolio review
exactly let's talk about percentages and
and what index are you buying is it one
are you buying multiple indexes
all right so I'm gonna break this down
into four categories category one I'm
just gonna call it the big account I'm
not gonna say who I use because I don't
want people looking after me or going
after me the second thing so there's the
big account which is the earnings from
my sale there's other Liquid account
which I'll talk about there's non-liquid
stuff and there's private company stuff
okay okay so the big the big account
I have 79 of that in vti so that's just
a Vanguard Total Index Fund another 15
of the pie chart is in short-term
treasuries which are currently yielding
I think 4.9 and I think it's like a
60-day term meaning
um every 60 days as of now uh we're
rebiting rebuying them they could be 90
days I forget but the short term and
then six percent in a real estate fund
that buys Walgreens I think it's called
like Oak
oak tree or I don't even know just some
boring thing that like owns like either
hundreds or thousands of Walgreen
buildings and Walgreens releases the
buildings and year to date vti up 19 one
year chart 15 5-year chart 57 that's
fine I'll take that all day uh what's
vti historically over the last 30 years
I think it's like eight percent a year
maybe yeah
so that it's just boring stuff and then
bonds prior to like when the economy was
killing it like three years ago I think
Bonds were like one percent now they're
like five percent and so I'll take that
all day and I think like a savings
account like a high yield savings
account is also like three or four
percent
um which is where I keep cash which is
basically all a way of saying wealth
preservation at this point which is not
where most people are at wealth creation
is where most people are at wealth
preservation is where you're at where
you're basically like
um
you're just trying not to lose the nest
egg the big the big account let's say
it's about
just keep up with inflation maybe beat
it a little bit
um okay the whole Market goes down I'm
Diversified I will also go down but less
so than somebody who was concentrated
bets trying to make a bunch of money
yes my opinion is that most people if
they are trying to make a lot of money
should try to make money through
starting a company or owning equity in a
company
and then as their cash flow comes in as
long as they don't need that to start
another business they should mostly do
what I'm doing which is what I've done
before I did this I was just in wealth
front and by the way you said this on a
different podcast I think it's worth
saying so you're like I wanted to be
kind of like Rich by 30 ish and you're
like to do that
basically have to start a business uh
and not only that I think you the the
likelihood of selling a business and
getting there is probably higher because
if you start a company at the age of 21
and you want to earn 10 million dollars
you could assume that more likely than
not your first three years you're going
to make minimum wage or in my case I
made 20 grand a year uh I made two
thousand dollars a month is when I paid
myself for the first two years of my
business so that gets you to like the
age of 25 which means you have to
average something like two or three
million dollars a year in profit uh
because you got to get taxed and that
will accumulate to like 10 million
dollars I think that's very very
challenging and I think it's a little
bit about selling yeah that's that's the
differentiation here it's about selling
versus uh
yeah cash flowing your way there that's
my opinion yes and the way that my like
quote big account works is I keep
roughly 100 to 200 000 in my checking
account any number or savings account
whatever you'll use any number above
that goes straight into my investment
fund this big account all right the
second one
I got a sugar mama have I told you that
how is she what's her name her name's
Sarah I've been with her for nine years
and she's my sugar mama my wife actually
made money before I did my wife uh went
to Penn very very smart woman went to an
Ivy League school got a job at Facebook
and then worked at Airbnb she's been
there for like six or seven years Airbnb
went public in December I think of 2021
we thought that they were going to go
out of business we didn't think Airbnb
was going to work out turns out they did
awesome I think when she started working
there I think the her uh the the
valuation of Airbnb was 10 billion it
could have been 18. I don't remember
when it iPod I think it was a hundred
billion I don't know what it is today
but it's tens of billions her stock did
wonderful so we own a bunch of Airbnb
stock of which we have sold none of it
what are you looking at Airbnb stock
right now 93 billion 93 billion so I
think it was like 8 billion during the
pandemic if I remember correctly I don't
remember exactly
we haven't sold a lick of that the other
stock of which we own
is HubSpot when I sold to HubSpot I was
given a bunch of stock I have not sold
any of it other than the amount that I
had to take out to pay taxes uh and
that's like a legal thing like they they
automatically take that out my intention
is to not sell any of that in the next
five years
um maybe I will maybe I won't as of now
I don't need the money I like both
Airbnb and I like HubSpot I'm not
selling any of that at the moment I also
have a 401k that I've always maxed out
and then I have Bitcoin that I bought in
2014 that basically has just sat there
dormant forever and I don't even know
what it is now but right I have not sold
any of it have you ever sold Bitcoin
yeah I've sold Bitcoin at a couple
different points each time I sold was a
poor decision uh I don't know if I tell
you the first time I sold so I bought
Bitcoin like back was like 300 or stuff
like that that's my original original
buy I feel like 400 was my average and
um it shot up to I don't know three
thousand four thousand at one point I go
to a wedding
and my aunt I think I told the story
before my aunt who's like you know an
Indian Auntie is I'm I walk into a
conversation she's having with her
friends and she's she literally goes oh
yeah ethereum is very good and I was
like
I was like my aunt's talking about
ethereum and saying it's very good and I
was like well how could you say it's
good
ethereum it used to be this price now
it's despised it's very good and I was
like oh it's good because the price is
going up but I was like pretty sure
there's bubbles I've read something
about this this is I think the moment
when like your Indian Auntie you know on
the east coast is talking about assets
that like you know are good because they
go up and telling her friends they gotta
buy and I'm like this is gonna be a
bubble and
um I was right and wrong so I
immediately go and I try to liquidate
everything I try to sell the whole thing
everything I have coinbase limits wait
was it really because of that literally
because of that I so like that night I
could try to sell everything coinbase is
limiting me because you can't just sell
like lots of lots of stuff at once
they're like you can only sell like I
don't know 15 grand at a time or
something like that so I'm trying to Max
it out every day and try to sell and um
and at some point I got time by the
fifth day or whatever I was like okay
let me just leave whatever else is there
it's fine and it kind of wore off
um
Bitcoin shoots up to 19 000 in like the
next two months and I was like oh my God
what am I doing I miss timed the bubble
and then it goes back down to like
whatever 3000 I was like I feel good now
and I was like this is stupid I
shouldn't just feel good and bad I
shouldn't try to time this basically
um I either believe in this or I don't
in the long term and I should just dude
I can't believe that you let your aunt
that one story sway like change your
actions oh that's happened to me
multiple I told you about the Tesla one
too I obviously owned a ton of like the
only stock I owned early on was Tesla
but back then Tesla was like very like
kind of like a young stock it was like
maybe like a two or three billion dollar
evaluation maybe five and um what's it
now like 600 billion or a trillion or
something it went up to basically close
to a trillion
um now I don't know what it says I can't
even do that math so what's a thousand
dollars in Tesla that's stupid I had a
very small amount of money at a college
I had like made like 25k in my first job
or something like that I saved enough to
like invest that much 25 30k or
something and I did the math once uh
yeah it's at 900 billion now so it would
have been basically I remember when I
had done the math
it was like oh that 25k would have been
like six million dollars by now
um if I just held and instead um I went
on Reddit and there's like I don't know
if you don't read it there's all these
like it's called like Tesla Q it's
basically like a group of people that
believe that Tesla is like going to zero
slash like
maybe it's like fraudulent and there's
like all these liposed they say that
they have fake cars right like like
they're Photoshop images they're not
fake cars but like lots of other things
like that like there would be like guys
who'd be like gosh
there's this Garage in Phoenix and look
at this and he would go to this garage
and it was only Tesla's parked on six
stories that he's walking everybody he's
like they're stashing them here so that
you can't tell where they're like
because if they just leave them in the
factory lot it's clear they're not
selling they're piling up he's like look
at this this one has and he's like
putting his finger on it's got dust he's
like look at this this hasn't moved in
months and I was like he's right thank
you you slash 333 kitty kitty like you
know and I was like just taking all
these signals from people on Reddit that
were like look at it and I think at one
point they had had like 15 different
CFOs and I was like that does seem fishy
why have so many CFOs come looked at the
books and left in a very short period of
time that doesn't sound right
and I basically took all these signals
and I sold and I was like so I tripled
my investment or quadrupled my
investment and I was like yeah I'm
getting out of the top boys and then uh
you know like 100x since then so yeah it
wasn't really it wasn't really and
that's the second time that's happened
to you the first time it happened to you
was with stripe when you had a job offer
I think at stripe no no I blew the the
interview I didn't get the offer the guy
was like um
I only applied to one job it was striped
back in 2011 or 12. so I would have been
like employee 20 at stripe
which is like a guaranteed like if you
if you stick it out and you're there for
four or five years or seven years and
you kind of like work your way up a
little bit even at a junior level entry
position probably would have ended up
over like a seven year period making
somewhere between 10 and 20 million
dollars and um
my mentor
is the mentor of the guy who's
interviewing me that's his mentor right
the mentors have a pretty big influence
if the mentor says hey this person's
amazing you're like oh thank you Sensei
like I I'll listen
I he my mentor had written a blog post
saying
I met this kid he's 21 years old he's an
entrepreneur and he's got the highest
like bias for action of anybody I've met
in the last 10 years and I was like Wow
glowing five-star review basically I
hand it to this guy this guy's like wow
if John thinks this about you
let's do the interview anyways as a
formality uh yeah we got to do it but
like I'm so excited to talk and we talk
and somehow
I blew like a 30 30 30 point lead during
the interview where I um he's like okay
so like you know let's this is kind of
like a sales position like you know sell
me a piece of software that you really
liked
I was like I was like sell me this pen a
um I was like I was like so what I would
do is I would basically just ask him a
bunch of questions he said no no like
ring ring hello like just do it pretend
and I was like
and I just I don't know like I don't
know what I said but whatever I said at
the end he's like yeah that wasn't very
good
um yeah I don't think this is a sales
probably not your thing you're probably
not that good at this so um you know
maybe there's another position we could
look for and I was so embarrassed at
that point or whatever I was like ah
this this guy basically rejected me and
said maybe there's some other role for
you like you know down in the basement
yeah maybe you could fold someone's
laundry one of the engineers laundry and
I was like all right [__] it I'm gonna
go for this other job instead and the
inner the guy was like uh he was like so
Sean what do you know about stripe and
like the banking system Sean's like uh
well I like money I would like I would
like to have some more of it
White Stripes uh Crest Whitening Stripes
sorry sorry those are strips uh let's
see Adidas logo you
ever been Stripes comedian store love it
uh that's how that interview went so
that blew it you blew that one but
that's okay that's okay you let emotions
sway you and I'm gonna give you a a
lesson here in that I never do that so
it's okay your weakness is my strength
so it's good because I don't sell
anything as I like to say I've lost more
money than most people have ever made
I'm such a good investor that I've lost
more money than you can dream of making
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
we uh when we sold the HubSpot I think
the stock was 367 I think it went up to
like 860 and it was it was amazing and
then it went down to like 250 and I
remember thinking like oh man is this
right is this right what do I do and so
like that that that definitely impacts
me like I definitely want to stop by the
way I literally did it with the HubSpot
thing I bought HubSpot stock
bring it right around when you when you
sold and then it went up and it was like
oh and everything was going up during
that period of time and uh then when the
whole Market crashed I was like you know
what I don't really want to be in the
stock market right now this isn't very
fun I don't know like there's all these
one again Tesla Q there's all these
warning signs about where the economy is
going
um I think I have a much bigger Edge
just like in my own businesses and in
private businesses let me just get out
of like Public Market stock picking
which I'm not like I don't know if I'm
very good or very bad at it but I just
think generally is a bad strategy to to
take to to your investing and um yeah I
basically sold almost the exact bottom
of the markets
and there's a guy somewhere in air
traffic control he's like the Bottom's
in he's out he's out let's move
most people only hit rock bottom once in
their life that's like the point of the
phrase
yeah
somebody was asking me this later today
they were like they're like oh so what
are you doing with your kind of
Investments I'm explaining what I do and
they're like um
so what do you like you know what do you
do for like your safety net or whatever
like
and I was like
safe like you're looking at it he's like
what do you mean I was like
am I still me if I'm still me I'm safe
like what do you I could lose all this
who cares I can get I can lose all of it
I'd make it all back like I have no I am
the safety net I you know a bond
portfolio is not my safety net my 401k
that's locked up till I'm 65. I don't
think of that as my safety net I am my
safety net and that's uh I think that's
an approach honestly uh if you're like
High Caliber I see so many people that
are high like really high caliber people
that play it so safe with their finances
I would kind of it was one of these
people and
you never look bad
but I also think you leave so much room
where like you didn't need to like have
you spent a dollar
or like have you spent more than 10 of
the money from the hustle sale no way
definitely not five percent have you
even spent a dollar from that account
no no I've never pulled money out of my
big account the most expensive thing I
bought was a hundred thousand dollar car
of which I think you bought three like
last month so
I'm not that I'm not Persian okay I'm
India
you've got three all-white g-wagons
that's all I'll say so so the thing uh
you you know this is one way I think
about it like you
um worked for 10 years every day to
build this company and you sold it you
achieved the thing you exactly wanted
and not a dollar has moved in like two
years or three years or you haven't like
moved a dollar from it in a way
you bought you you spent 10 years to
save up for this power tool and then you
just leave it in the case and um and and
I I don't know if like I'm not saying
that my way is right but I also know
that for me
uh My Philosophy is money is a tool to
be used to enhance your life and if
you're not really using it
and then you work hard to like go get
more money it's like that really all
compute for me what is the way you think
about that to like make that feel right
I think that's an incredibly Fair
criticism and my joke is when Warren
Buffett talks about the long-term View
and I'm like dude you're [__] 95.
there is no long-term view like that
doesn't exist right
um and so it to to criticize myself I am
horrible at spending money ramit safety
who we have on the Pod he does a really
good job of like saying like look you
can earn income and you should be good
at that you also have to get good at
spending I'm quite bad at spending I
think it's just rooted in emotional
instability and being insane uh I think
that these are just like personality
defects and oftentimes what makes you
good at saving makes you bad at spending
and I think that it's uh like a
therapist issue that you need to work
out and so I think that's an incredibly
Fair criticism I think the truth is half
is is not quite halfway in the middle I
think I should of what you believe in
what I believe I think it's more like I
should loosen up a bit right but yeah
that's it I I think typically what I've
seen is people who earn a lump sum like
a startup where they are poor and then
suddenly they're not poor those people
tend to be more like me where they're
really tight wide and they're Frugal and
they're cheap and that causes a lots of
anxiety people who earn a significant
amount of cash flow throughout the years
and get used to it they tend to be a
little bit more offensive and a little
bit less conservative but I think it's
rooted definitely in like childhood
trauma and [__] like that like just like
how you're raised you know what I mean
just like you're running out of money
I'm gonna share without sharing
somebody's name
um some a friend of ours sent me a
presentation that they did
um
that they made kind of like about their
life as part of uh like one of these
like peer group things not Hampton but a
different one so we don't we don't plug
no other names have no other groups on
this podcast that's right thank you I
appreciate that so
so I sent me this thing I thought it was
really great basically it's like you
know here's my life story and here's
what I do with my money and I he had a
couple slides I thought were really good
so one was uh this person had sold their
business for over 100 million dollars so
they have like a nine figure exit of
their business
and the next slide is so it's like
here's the picture of me the day we sold
for over 100 million dollars
um
next day it's like I bought this bike um
this bike is this two thousand dollar
bike it's an awesome bike most expensive
purchase uh most expensive item I've
owned
since it's been like 10 years or
something like it's like whoa
um until I recently bought a condo
finally like last year uh this was the
most expensive item I owned love this
bike and then I was like okay
interesting
um
and then and then uh there's another
slide that I like so so it goes um yeah
one slide that said top five Financial
mistakes that I've learned to cope with
love that title and there's five
interesting ones about basically like
sold this too early sold this too early
was gonna buy this and talk myself out
of it because there was a fee associated
with it I would have made like 20
million bucks on that you know so so I
think that's just a great exercise to go
on which is like
you could survive a bunch of bad
mistakes and if you're gonna play the
game any like any good startup investor
has an epic anti-portfolio a bunch of
businesses that they passed on that they
should have invested in and um that's
that is part of playing the game you
can't play the you know it's like being
a basketball player and you know that
Michael Jordan commercial where he's
like I've missed 3 000 game winning
shots or whatever it's like yeah that's
what happens when you're you play You're
Gonna Miss shots and like you can't yeah
everyone has like
I literally know 15 people that have the
same Uber story
um like that was like that was like the
famous one for years which is I passed
on Uber I passed on Uber everyone said I
passed on Uber
um like I I know a ton of people have
said that I think Gary vaynerchuk like
in the beginning of his book he like
gives a compliment to Travis kalanick
the founder it calls him out as like you
know yeah he's like dude I think my wife
he's like I think my wife my children
and Travis kalanick meaning I was super
close with them and I still passed on
that and that cost me a hundred million
dollars exactly I think that's like a
famous story he says so yeah everyone
has that story
um let me give you two other slides he
says then it's there's two slides called
my effed up relationship with money I
think I can read this let me see so it
says
um I work hard to make money and I got
good at it but then I hoard the money I
make I put it in bank accounts I look at
it constantly and besides hoarding I
know money I know that money is good for
one other thing making more money
um you know like that's uh that's
something I realize and it's like you
know I really like put a lot of my own
self value on money here's some things
that I do that are dumb about money uh
like I feel guilty spending on myself
um my parents were the same way they
they were spent on their kids or spend
on like other things that they wouldn't
spend on themselves and um that's
annoying they did it and now I'm doing
it
um he said I bought a business that was
a cash flow business and I said okay
this is my cocaine fund
um all the profit from this I must spend
on something hedonistic unless I must
spend I can't save this money didn't
work still saved it
um and he goes uh he goes I'm
comfortable losing 500k on an investment
just like that but if you said five
spend 500k to improve your life and I
guarantee it will improve your life
I can't I can't do it I can't get myself
to do it I'm the exact same way I've
been looking at it I should be helping
I've been looking at your company
well I've been looking at your company
Shepard I think it's like 3 000 a month
for an assistant of which I desperately
need but I'm like three thousand dollars
a month
but well the it's not a fee uh whatever
the payment is whatever you pay 30 of
their salary as a as a Headhunter Bounty
once so that's it so it'll be like three
it'll be like three grand for the year
is for most people that's like let's say
an average
but I mean I have to pay the uh the the
person's uh the person's salary and I'm
like well that's 36 Grand a year but if
you do that over five years at the rate
that we're growing right now that's
ninety thousand dollars like I'm ruining
the compounding she might really be
valuable and that might be a 15-year
relationship now I'm talking about a 500
000 investment but I could also put that
in vti and it would compound eight
percent and now you've talked yourself
out of it
when I was buying my wife's wedding ring
I was like oh man this is the most
expensive thing I've ever bought that's
a lot of money but I guess if we're
married for 80 years because we might
live to be like 110 that means that
that's only 800 a year and that's okay
do you know what I mean like there's all
these weird mental gymnastics that crazy
people like me have to do so this guy is
he an immigrant is this guy an immigrant
you're talking about it's 100 most
immigrants that I've been around have or
not most but this sounds like a very
much an immigrant problem right uh of
which I'm the exact opposite of an
immigrant but that's why that's why I
like those guys I identify with them
um you know there's uh we had this this
funny experience yesterday where um
another friend who also
mega mega wealthy
um
when we met him and we met up with this
person in person they were like you know
what I really want to like shift into
like family mode like I'm ready to like
meet somebody have a kid like you know
like I want to do that part of life now
and we're like that makes total sense
um good on you you are you know you did
the money thing the business thing you
you you scratched that it you proved you
could do it now you're in your 30s and
you're saying you know what I'm not
really I don't really have a partner I
don't have kids that seems fun I do see
myself as a family guy I want to do that
so that was where we left a conversation
and now um my business partner Ben Levy
he's like the man with like checking in
on people
checks in on everybody and um so he's
always providing me the stream of
updates about like what people are up to
and it's great and so he's like uh yo
that friend he's like he's like doing
something new and um and I'm like uh
like not just doing one thing news I get
these like four projects he's cooking up
and I was like oh that's interesting
like what happened to the whole like I
want to actually focus on like like
finding a partner or starting a family
like whatever that he's like oh yeah he
still wants to do that it's like we
start in four companies I mean that
doesn't seem like that's gonna be very
conducive to like you know put your
focus on something right and it's like
yeah I agree and I go how come this
keeps happening like we have so many
smart friends and I said there's a big
difference between smart and wise and I
think that's what we're seeing is
basically with a lot of smart friends
that are not that wise about like
decision making so they're intelligent
for sure
um
but they make decisions don't really
make sense if you zoomed out a little
bit how old's this person I don't know
like I don't know mid 30s or something
like that I think some of that will come
with age I think that we're in a weird
circle of which many of the listeners
listening to this they have a higher
income than most people their age and I
think that like sometimes maybe your
earning power is ahead of your brain
power or wisdom power you know what I
mean that's what I'm saying like I'm not
telling you you you got to go get
married and have kids but if you told me
you wanted to get married to have kids
and then instead you're spending all
your time doing these other things that
are going to completely make you busy
and if I asked you why didn't you why
hasn't this happened already it's like
oh I was so heads down in my company
it's like cool so why are you getting
heads down in four companies now that
doesn't make sense either and I texted
Ben I go man we're you know I'm guilty
of this in other areas of my life right
because again if you spot it you got it
so anytime I noticed something to other
people I'm like where in my life do I
make the same stupid mistake and I was
like oh it'd be like like yesterday I
canceled I did something I very rarely
almost never this I canceled my workout
because I was like had two doctor's
appointments and I was like if I if I do
this workout in the middle of the day
then I'm just not gonna get any work
done today cancel my workout I was like
but my number one goal right now in life
is to get fit I would get more value out
of becoming more fit than making another
dollar
yeah 54 days left I think right uh yeah
Monday uh no I'm on 49 uh 49 days left
yep
um yeah 49 days left to get abs I'm
eight weeks away from being that guy
um so so but but I guess like the point
is that's an area of my life where I
make a stupid decision that's an unwise
decision to say hey
on one day I said this is my main goal
and then three days later I'm
prioritizing something else above my
main goal what that doesn't make any
sense and same way this person's doing
that with your relationship their main
goal is to get married have kids but
they prioritize a bunch of other stuff
and I was like that's not intelligence
that's wisdom like that's basically
having good judgment and
um I realized that like wisdom or good
judgment is the thing that's most short
in Supply and the most valuable because
it's like a lever you don't have to be
that hard working or that smart if you
have great judgment if you pick the
right things to focus on pick the right
people to work with uh pick the right
place to live you don't have to be like
9000 IQ you don't have to know
everything about everything you don't
have to be the hardest worker
but if you have poor judgment no amount
of hard work or like intelligence really
saves you you kind of screw yourself and
so it just really emphasized that point
to me about like you know smart does not
equal wise and the goal is wise not
smart I think that's a good one I like
that and it's like when you're driving
and you say everyone's such a horrible
driver it's like dude
you too uh it's like there's like some
weird emotion and logic that don't make
sense there um and then my final
accounts of which you can these last two
you're gonna have a lot of uh opinions
on the last one or the second to last
one is my non-liquid stuff of which it's
roughly 3.8 million dollars in real
estate of which I have a mortgage on my
house I think my house was 950 000 that
I bought I have a mortgage of like 550
left I own a ranch I own some vacant
Lots in Austin and I'm a small owner in
some storage deals uh a Brooklyn
building and one or two small things
um and the other non-liquid stuff is
Angel Investing now here's what I do and
you tell me if I'm wrong
I reduced I value it at so the principal
sum that I put in Plus I even put a
large discount on that of which it's not
that would be around five hundred
thousand dollars of startup Investments
the way that I see that is I've done
roughly 50 I think
40 will probably not work 10 will work
of which three might pay back everything
plus a little bit and I've reduced the
principle by a significant amount just
in assuming future net worth and
anything above that whatever maybe it
will work what do you think about that
yeah I think basically startup investing
is uh
it's so it's so long time Horizon right
like you have to assume that these are
going to take seven to ten years before
they pay out so even if they are worth X
they're not really worth X to you yet uh
they're these little eggs that are that
are you know going to be hatching and so
I'm with you basically when I calculate
I I never calculate net worth because I
think that's uh kind of useless because
it takes into account illiquid things
that are going to either like go to zero
or go way up in value like my own
businesses are gonna either go to zero
or go way up in value most likely and
they're illiquid so what does it matter
I can't do anything with them right now
anyhow so I I basically only calculate
liquid net worth when I calculate it and
uh so that doesn't include any of my own
businesses and I also don't include any
startup Investments because it's not
liquid yet that doesn't mean it's not
valuable but it's just not liquid yet so
I don't I don't even apply the discount
because it doesn't matter it's not in my
calculation
and that's my last category which is
private companies so those include like
any course I do this podcast speaking
fees which is like called par media I
assume that has zero Equity value I live
off that income and then the next big
company is Hampton as of today I assume
that is worth zero I've taken zero
salary from it I will likely take a
dividend at the end of the year but
until that business hits like
40 or 50 million in Revenue in my head I
assume it's worth zero and I do not
include
um I do not include any of the private
businesses that I operate or own as part
of my net worth so we are totally
aligned on that part like by e-commerce
I don't I don't include it in the
calculation even though that business is
doing great you you include that as zero
still yeah well I just I don't Market at
zero I just I'm not calculating total
net worth I'm only calculating liquid
um so if I try to calculate net worth
yeah I didn't include it I'd put some
conservative number there but I don't
even really bother because what's the
point in fact I think the whole network
thing is like um
not a great
thing to up like I kind of in search of
a better metric well there's earning so
income do you measure income but then
income is like only things that are you
know it's gonna buy us way too hard to
things that are only you know generating
cash flow today
um so it's not going to count really any
like no I mean
do you measure your income on a monthly
basis I measure my every month I like do
like a report where I look at like all
right what was my income this month and
where did it come from yeah not
religiously but it's it's mostly like
steady I can I kind of know the one or
two things that are variable I'm like oh
that's what that was at this month plus
you know it's it's like in the same
range roughly
um so yeah I know I know what it's
coming in every month I know roughly
what's coming out every month I don't
really keep track of spending too much
um I I'll kind of calculate spending
every couple months just to be like am I
did I add anything significant here
um what's your spend right now I think I
spend maybe 25 or 30 000 a month yeah I
think I'm at 30 30k a month of burn life
life expenses and and I feel that that's
a lot that sounds like a lot to me that
sounds insane to me we have a friend who
told us that they are currently spending
300 000 a month and I was like gasping I
was like I can't comprehend that and
then they listed it all out and I was
like yeah that definitely adds up but
that's just like you do need the jet I
mean what are you gonna do without it
it was insane to me I've got another
friend that spends eighty thousand and
uh I'm like gasping right but I guess
like everything changed when you get
when you get to different levels
um
uh but so anyway that's kind of like my
portfolio I want to say that hey this
isn't advice but also um
I basically do the most simple
conservative stuff I use tiller have you
heard of tiller I think the website is
tillerhq.com it's like a plug-in and I
track this in Google Sheets what do you
do you track anything like your accounts
I don't understand these apps because
I'm like I'm not connecting my [__] to
these random startup apps like you know
I don't wanna I don't want to put all my
stuff into these apps so I because I'm
not that concerned with it in general
um
you know the fewer things that you're
concerned about the better in general
yes surely like occasional checks and
balances so every three months I sit
down and by hand I write down I write
out
where I'm at with liquid stuff where I'm
at income wise and where I'm at monthly
burn wise every three months I do that
but there's like a there's like a
logistical problem let's say your wife
has a 401k from her job from like eight
years ago yeah and you have one from
each job that you've had and you haven't
combined them that's like six accounts
potentially or five accounts plus a
checking plus a savings plus uh like
let's say that you each have like a
Robinhood account or an e-trade account
plus uh her previous before you were
married maybe checking your savings I
mean like it kind of can accumulate
whether you have money or not that you
have eight or ten accounts and like what
happens if you die and she doesn't know
about all of them or vice versa do you
know what I mean yeah we do have that
problem which is if I die I don't think
she's gonna be able to like know or find
or access a bunch of stuff especially
the crypto stuff how's it going to get
to that I've told her three times and
I'm like you're not really paying
attention enough to remember this like
nine years from now if something happens
it's like I don't know what's gonna
happen with that I I that I am a little
bit concerned about
um however
the rest of the stuff again I just do it
by hand and I make a day out of it I
treat it like a spa day it's like right
I think you talked about this concept of
worry time you're like I just scheduled
some worry time in the future that's
what I do with this I don't call it
worry time because I'm not trying to
feel worried during it but same thing I
just scheduled a little a day every
three months I'm like oh today's the day
it's basically like let's have a little
Financial picnic all right let me open
up some of these baskets and see what's
inside and um and let me take stock of
what's going on and I think once a
quarter for me is the right
amount of energy I'm trying to spend on
on this and I just don't really want to
think about it otherwise do you know
anyone who's crazier than you I mean I
view you as being quite crazy I've got
one friend that uh made like 150 million
dollars and they invested like the
majority of it in only two things their
next company and a house and they're
like I basically don't own any like
bonds equities I've got very little
savings so I consider that person being
crazier than you right or a similar
amount of crazy but potentially at a
larger scale
are all of your circle of friends like
you or do many of them say the same
thing like I'm saying which is like man
you're not conservative enough would you
say crazy do you s like is this kind of
like oh this bum on the streets a little
crazier is it like wow that she's hot
but she's crazy like which one am I my
hot girl crazy or am I bum crazy more
like bet it all in on black uh like like
tuition money or this game of roulette
right
um I don't view myself as that crazy I
think that uh
I think I have a pretty healthy view on
money I'll explain it to you in a few
sentences number one money is a tool to
enable a better lifestyle that's what
it's for that's how I use it so that's
the first thing that includes spending
on lifestyle but it also includes
learning things by Angel Investments I
don't view as the absolute Optimum way
for me personally to make money but I
love them because I learned so much
about where the world is going from
startups and I like being around
entrepreneurs that's those are my people
so I'm using money as my tool to like
make my life more like how I want
um
so I use money as a tool that's the
first thing money is a tool to enable a
better lifestyle I think I abide by that
law the second thing is
um money's no fun when you're stressed
about it so there's basically like a
strategy that just says
I don't need to
um I don't need to be stressed about
this so what is my amount of money that
I know is my like safety net so like you
know basically can I have two to three
years of expenses put away that's just
in like it could be in nothing it could
just be literally sitting in a bank
account doing absolutely nothing but
it's not doing nothing it's enabling me
to be free with the rest of the money
because I know that if I lost everything
if somehow everything went to zero
I would still have three years of Runway
and again
I'm me I am my own station if you give
me three years of Runway I'll have it
all back and more by then uh like you
know if I needed to uh to make money a
focus and so I do that so to me I'm like
if I have three years of life expenses
um put away what what am I worried about
right
so I do that
um the third thing is
I know if I'm in which gear am I in
wealth creation mode or wealth
preservation mode so well I view myself
still as in wealth creation mode you
know when I sold my company it wasn't
for as much money as you sold your
company for I think if I had sold my my
company for as much as you did
I might do things slightly differently
but I still view like most of my
investments as like more on the
aggressive side more concentrated bets
in things that I believe in and I know
I'm gonna make mistakes I'm gonna have
some things that go to zero I'm gonna
sell some things at the wrong time I
would say the only leak in my game is
really just that I sell things at all I
really just shouldn't sell like the the
only investment mistake I've made is
just selling okay but are you actually
gonna you've just acknowledged and we'll
go well we can make fun of me after this
but you've acknowledged that so are you
making that yes exactly so I made that
but okay so you're not gonna sell ever
or often uh I'm buying things that I
basically have to uh I basically default
to say this is only you have to break
glass if you're going to sell this so
basically like you have to really have a
reason like either you need the money
and you gotta sell the thing or
something in the world has changed that
caused you to like re-underwrite this
now I would argue I kind of did that
with this um
the last time that I sold when basically
like
uh the postcovid kind of like what's
going money printing is going on what's
going on in the economy everything all
the stocks crash
I thought okay we've had a 13-year bull
market
um we're probably not just gonna have
six months of bad times and then back to
the good times again like I still kind
of believe that that's true
um but I should say
I wasn't in a place to re-underwrite
that that those Investments because I
was now thinking about macro stuff where
like
if I'm sending 30 of my time on
Wikipedia that means I'm not informed
enough to be making an intelligent
decision about this uh you know I'm like
I'm learning about it but where do you
get the information from do you get it
from current people so for example I
like to I prefer to get information I
try to read books that are at least 30
or 40 years old and to figure out like
um I try to learn about stuff what's it
called like the Lindy effect where it's
like I try to learn about stuff that as
is has been repeated many many many
times and isn't exactly new for and and
the counter example that is when biology
said all the crazy stuff about
um what was his argument that bitcoin's
going to a million because for this
reason that [__] scares me and I'm like
I don't understand that that's so new
and it legitimately scares me that's
what I do I don't try to do that because
um what I find happens with that is I
already have an opinion in my head and
then I just go find evidence of it right
I already want to hold the stock forever
so then I go find the Lindy effect that
says Ah lindifex says that this thing's
gonna stay valuable because it's been
valuable and I'll like cling to that
evidence but it's really just
reinforcing some bias I already had in
my head so instead what I do and you
can't learn everything right like you
can't just say I'm gonna go learn the
world of like Finance like this is too
broad it's impossible to do so here's
what I do
I go through and I say what are people
that I consider to be smart saying and
thinking right now and I go try to line
up contenders it's like here's Theory a
about where the world is going right now
about what here's thesis a here's thesis
B here's thesis C and then I basically
say inherently does one of them just
intuitively make more sense to me does
it does it resonate in my gut that one
of these just feels more true than the
others okay that's the first test second
test what evidence do they have that
backs up their belief let me now stack
the evidence okay now which one appears
to be the strongest thesis so instead of
going and trying to learn about the
topic I take people who already like
have strong opinions about this topic
and I go try to find what is the
spectrum of opinions about this so on
one end you have biology who's like do
you actually talk to them or just
consume not always sometimes but like
not always like you know like biology
for example he's just very public about
his thesis so you don't need to like
talk to him right it's like he's
publishing every day what he believes to
be true he's like I moved out of America
I got out of the dollar and here's the
sources I'm citing that I'm tracking
that basically says that the banking
system is insolvent
um that the you know the money printing
is you know is out of control inflation
is higher than they're admitting and
that this is what what is the result of
this it's X right then you have Ray
dalio that says look
I've been studying Empires and all
Empires come to an end here's the cycles
that they go through and I think that
America's at the tail end of the cycle
so you go read that book you go watch
his talks you're like all right that's
one another thesis you have some people
who say
um no you know what this is gonna bounce
back because even with all the problems
America has the dollar is still the best
thing we got out there
um and that when all the all the
countries in the world get weaker
they'll actually flee to the whatever
this relatively strongest currency is
and maybe that's the dollar and the
dollar is going to drink the whole
milkshake basically it's like all right
cool
um that I I didn't make this some
something I forgot it's called like the
the straw that drinks the shake or some
[__] like that people don't talk about
it From There Will Be Blood he goes if I
had a long shrug all the way over there
I drink your milkshake so I drink it up
so you basically line up a bunch of
arguments and then you kind of like you
litigate them like a lawyer you're like
what evidence do you have that supports
this
um what examples do you have and then
you basically say look okay even if I
don't know what's totally true
can I hedge so it's like you know what I
don't think this guy's right but he
might be and if he is what hedge would I
wish I had in place just in case and
like you know this is the most likely
thing to be true so then let me like
allocate things that way so that's
generally how I try to approach things I
do like that I would say
however I know my my Achilles heel in
this is that I do get drawn to the to a
bit of the sexy Underdog opinion the
conspiracy opinion the
um to kind of like
this is the country the most contrarian
opinion appeals to be inside because I'm
like oh [__] there could be a mystery
that we're on to that nobody else really
fully like people don't believe it that
makes me want to believe it more
and I think that's led me to make too
drastic of a decision in the past of
like selling all of my Tesla or selling
you know 70 of my stocks or whatever
like you know it doesn't have to be that
dramatic like I should just put into
place smaller hedges in those and track
them and be like cool if that's true
then six months from now I might be
seeing more of this so let me check in
at that time and see if the signals have
grown stronger or or faded
right now you're in a little bit in
advice giving mode because
I'm asking you questions but to swap it
who do you look up to where you're like
I need to be more like them when it
comes to
personal finance
I wouldn't say there's somebody on the
personal finance like managing your own
money but there are a lot of people that
I look up to or or find I talk to to get
ideas on
what game are they playing to generate
more money so
I don't I don't really seek or I'm not
that interested frankly and like well
who are those people
you obviously like Andrew our friend
Andrew Wilkinson tiny tiny.com he took
the company public so you can actually
go and see the numbers so you like
Andrew yeah I like Andrew like Xavier uh
I like Xavier yes
um side bulky I think had really I I had
really interesting things to say about
what he does like I'll give you just a
funny example so Syed by the way he owns
this thing called WP why it's called
awesome Corp he started as a Blog called
wpbeginner which was a Blog on how to
use WordPress now he owns tons of
Wordpress plugins I don't know how big
it is but I bet it's worth half a
billion dollars of which I bet he owns
most of it and it probably does many
many tens of millions in revenue and
probably tens of millions in profit
right yes and uh yes as in directional
yes I don't know the exact numbers but
um he basically has a business that's
amazing that's a monopoly prints cash
and then he does interesting things with
his cache like he owns like I don't know
40 gas stations or some [__] like that
it's like why do you own gas stations
dude is that a good idea bad idea does
that take up a bunch of time or not he's
like no these are triple net leases I
just own the buildings that other people
operate in and they pay for all the
maintenance I was like oh okay
interesting
um so I did a call with him once and
he's like uh he's like yeah my he said
my mentor taught me one thing which was
uh uh okay you wanna you don't spend
it's kind of like I don't know the math
I'm gonna say a math term even though I
don't know math he's like you don't
spend like the first derivative money
he's like basically what most people do
is that cash comes in from the business
that they spend that money on life
expenses no no you only spend the second
derivative it's like cash let's say a
million dollars comes in from your
business you don't get to spend that
million is not spendable the million has
to be invested into something and that
the income from that investment that's
what you get to spend you do that you'll
never go broke and um and I was like oh
that's interesting he's like yeah so
like I wanted to have a kid before we
had a kid I bought a gas station gas
station makes six grand a month
that pays for this kid
[Laughter]
works I was like interesting again
thesis line it up say does that does
that seem like a way of life I'd like to
do maybe maybe not but like I want I
find it interesting because he says
different things than most people he
does different things than most people
and how he runs his life and how he runs
his businesses and what he does with the
money
um you know he was the one who was like
you know what
I love buying businesses like but
there's another strategy I do where I
buy these like 30 to 40 minority stakes
and businesses that I can help in these
two specific ways and they're they're
gonna keep running it so they get a
little liquidity they get to retain
control and I'm gonna help them break
through the plateau to get to the next
level he's like I love doing that I look
for those deals and so when I invested
in Shepard it was exactly that was I
exactly that mindset I was like what's a
great business that I already believe in
and I'm a customer a customer of that I
can buy a minority stake let them keep
running it
but then help them get to the next level
by doing these two things and um has
your contribution to that already do you
think that that your contribution has
paid dividends in their business yet
yeah of course yeah we're last two
months have been the highest two months
of the business in the history of the
business so it's great
um and for me that's great too right
like I've already I've already paid back
I don't know three three percent of my
money or something like that on on that
investment so like you know wow that
thing's gonna you know in terms of oh
could I put my money in the stock market
try to get eight percent or this thing's
clearly this thing's gonna do 200 a year
basically
um
I don't know unless something bad
happens so that's like you know a great
use of okay yes I maybe I sold my
whatever Amazon stock or whatever stock
HubSpot stock whatever it is
and I missed the kind of like a little
bit of the bounce back but I put that
money to work in a place where I felt
like I had a little more control and and
could see a path to a much greater
return
um with with more risk of course this
episode is like the personal finance
episode I'm very curious to see if you
listeners actually enjoy this stuff next
time we got to get back to like the
business building stuff because I think
that that is interesting to more people
and it's also interesting to me and you
but I'm very curious to see if this is
useful for people I like it I think this
is a good one what do you want to wrap
here yeah let's wrap it up all right we
have a bunch of stuff next week but
that's the pod
[Music]
thank you